welcome to this video playing a
beautiful mind from Switzerland all on
to lecture i M rated to 414 so let's see
what I can do here writing neighbor just
six points away from me okay the Slav
good old Slav yeah beautiful mind I
never saw that that movie is it a good
one supposed to be good let's see okay
and he probably knows his theory right
Knight c3 night d7 and so on ok I will
play a bit term more restraint Knight c3
is a bit more dangerous but still I can
show you the line num afterwards there
is some maybe I should have played this
anyway but ok that's III is a sharper
line where black cam only recently has
some found a new interesting reply which
was quite a funny story I I had found
this idea myself when I prepared a video
for for the ICC and only a couple of
days later I got the new book in the
mail I am by Boris a brook on the
classical Slav where he also had exactly
the same same idea that's weird why is
he allowing that giving me the bishop
here or allowing Bishop f4 with the
tempo is strange the bishop belongs on
is seven anyway in the structure so it's
a bit strange
and what okay cannot even playbook ba
gia I'm threatening to take take on b7
it's a bit awkward black still it's
still solid though typical sloth
business Bishop f4 mm-hm look so simple
getting this temple not sure though
really is this so great the bishop is
getting a kick with 95 probably anyway
but ok then i can return to d2 and may
be pushy fallen ok so this is what I
want to do get an e-form 95 I just go to
the two back now and and before I
sitting him next so 95 is really not
doing him any good ok you for now or
even I can even play 95 here in this
position then maybe you start with this
so that I'm winning a tempo here you for
maybe we should be for even then or a
far a formal solo this is quite a nice
position we should be for Queen
somewhere the other pawn here is hanging
on deform I should probably protect it
not sure however Bishop e3 or bishops
III I get probably Bishop e3
looking at the c5 braid yeah this I
expected really good I'm probably also a
good move once too once the trade a4 is
possible now a4 a5 threatening them the
b7 pawn want to do that in a mode where
a five if it's not possible so you
cannot freeze the queenside that's a
very nice position for wine very
difficult for black to to defend this
move like would be eight is always
answered by Bishop f4 okay the question
is now d 5 or not t5 d5 there's probably
five and it's it's fine but
now the black position esser typically
resilient D 5 D five different still
should be quite playable for black
yeah I want to prepare d5 the night on
c8 is not great anyway you know yeah i
was thinking d5 here g5 tending e5 take
stakes why i can maybe really take that
but ok let's let's get ahead threatening
me five now if I've and d6 so he
probably has to take somehow maybe he
can 5v5 Bishop c5 f6f for this what is
this is good to suspect how to how to
tell
but I need to increase my speed
definitely
yeah and I need to do that otherwise it
so this is all too lame play a slow
that's it is difficult for him rook c8 I
am giving up a pawn but take here takes
on seif what is better here ok keep it
to keep it simple just just win the porn
look look checks or queen takes rook
takes I'm not sure probably I should
exchange this locating win ok I don't
mind that now i'm getting the sea from
or 37 whatever
taking and Lucy one I think and rook c7
to come see some when I definitely need
my morning King involved our case
attacking a form hmm mp3 it's not ideal
now maybe this this rook c7 wasn't as
promising at that thought I was thinking
wookie for but he can really take it
despite the the checks yeah not easy the
tech technical this was bad allowing
look to g4 hmm ok a Bishop g4 I mean now
he's not threatening anything I have
everything covered
I check the phone
I don't I don't really see a convincing
way to win look edge for you may be
intending to take it oh we can just take
it wow I didn't see that at all what
happen ok check draw chafford don't
overdraw Arthur come on hard ground I
want to win this totally drawn position
with aid against three other sisters not
make any sense to me as often mentioned
in any decent time control we just draw
this I just blundered away d 5 this was
nonsense really I simply did a miss
countdown yeah awesome it certainly
should should be a close to win at the
outset but not easy and his King is
really quick here maybe yeah maybe I
should play it differently here after
king of 7 and just just get my king in
the game quickly hard to tell i mean i
don't think i played it really badly
king of tune he's just very quick if i
would be able to get to d4 it's not a
not a big problem but somehow he he
managed that this was probably bad yeah
maybe I cannot move the rock not
logically yeah the I Roxy for stupid
prom me if I do something like that it
could be as oops wrong type of position
look at this here what what is this move
if he moves the king king before I'm
making some progress and if he moves to
the bishop I get in Luke h7 for example
this is very good for me
yeah my idea was to play rookie for here
and push the King back but he can he can
probably just take that maybe I should
have done it anyway yeah yeah I actually
had to yank that but I thought well why
give up my passer but it's probably
probably a good trade yeah yeah that's a
good trade for me the age pawn is very
weak yeah this is what I should have
done okay I wanted to briefly as I
promised and show the opening line 93-97
for this is the most critical here and
as it turns out here black has a new
idea he for some time try to make this
work which is still on yeah an
interesting line I mean black is not
worse iam probably but it's it's it's
what Ricky and the new idea here is to
play a hive which is a very very
interesting concept the idea said after
this black is taking here and G takes
Knight eggs is okay for him and after
this black can play this funny move it's
quite quite nice the big point is that
white cannot I mean he can but it is not
it's not leading to anything after 95
like has a huge attack and wider
probably needs to for some a drawer
somewhere it's a bit much to show that
now if you if you're understand German
you can look at and our member of the
assessee you can do get my video series
or look in our works book or fire up
your engine if you are interested in
this line ok thanks for watching